[Space-Time, 1964/2014 by Jorge Otero-Pailos]
She's over 100 years old you know, god knows where
it's been, what it's seen.
This is just a little bit bigger, yeah but those, I think our apples are toobig.
This has too many, too many layers. So this is wrong.
This is you know, it's supposed to be a square corner I meanthere's rounded corners on these things.
It's the ammunition. 150 grain projectile travels over 2,600
feet per second.
They would just put their eyeball on it here, line this up with the backstop andthen anything between the end of the muzzle and the backstop that's on that line, that trajectory,
gets shot.
We have to make right now a sort of critical decision which is, do we shoot the bulleton the right or shoot the bullet on the left?
You see there's some groove markings on that bullet hole?
Those grooves are createdas the bullet rifles out of the barrel.
He can tell the direction the bullet is traveling and
rotating.
In fact the setup had to be in that direction, otherwise the bullet would be rotatingin the wrong direction. It doesn't come out of that barrel spiraling this way, it comes out spiralingthat way.
Do you want to recreate the image he printed, or do you want to recreate the negativehe shot and then do the reversal?
Let's shoot, as he shot it. We need to flip the cue. Debbie
said the negative was shot the other way.
So what we're gonna do now is take one test-fire of
the rifle and because we can't really see that
well through the three mil thick polyethylene
sheeting that is our cube over there, what we're
gonna do is punch a hole in both sides using
the bullet and it'll give us the trajectory
of the bullet and we can string a string from
the entrance hold of the exit hole and on that
line we can place the apple.
Test fire, test fire! Three, two, one. [Bullet firing]
Got it, thank you.
Theshell here and the shadow of the shell are not perfectly parallel.
And this side of the apple isthe backsplash here is pretty close but it's also higher than the stuff coming out of this
side.
Which means the backdrop has to be tilted.
[Crosstalk] It was gonna be here, yeah yeah well we know the bullet'sin here. That is right.
So the next step is set up the strobe.
So this is what's known as a piezo electric
trigger. Now the cool thing is that the bullet is
flying along at supersonic velocity and because
it's supersonic it has a sonic boom, a shock wave
that travels with the bullet in this case that
sonic boom is gonna rate back at a rather sharp
angle but when the sonic boom hits the mic, you fire the strobe.
#5 is "put in apple"
"and shoot."
Lights off please!
Fire! [Bullet fire]
Lights on please!
You know at some point we run out of apples,
at some point weget the backdrop so glocked up...
For the last time tonight.
Lights off please!
Fire! [Bullet fires]
Lights on please!
Line is clear, line is clear!
[Laughter]
What?
Oh that's gorgeous. Look at that!